[Music]
we know Britney Spears ex Kevin
Federline wants a bigger cut of child
support but today the big question
where's the money going
Jamie Spears will reportedly request
Federline's 2017 tax return a source
tells ET he wants to know quote where
the money is going
[Music]
k-fed already receives around twenty
thousand dollars a month to care for
their two sons twelve year old Sean
Preston and eleven year-old Jaden
according to a report Jamie believes
Kevin may be misusing that money to
provide for his four other children you
know how the kids o66 kid I didn't plan
it
how could you plan something like that
last year Federline told Vlad TV the
$20,000 in child support was not a some
determined by him it's definitely not
anything to brag about and it's not
something that I asked for even if
you're living in a mansion you don't
want your kids shouldn't be living in a
shack
Kevin's primary source of income has
been through DJing his niche brand of
celebrity allows him to command upwards
of $10,000 a gig this weekend he's
hosting his 40th birthday party at the
Crazy Horse 3 strip club in Vegas I
don't want to hear talk to the hand
cause the face ain't listening Kevin
first capitalized on his famous marriage
in 2005 with their 5 episode reality
series Britney and Kevin
chaotic so this is near the height of
her career why even bother with putting
this stuff out that's why I didn't quite
understand no no man you got me you know
that Jolie lasted about 15 minutes but
it was a really good 15
you
[Music]